this video is brought to you by
squarespace an all-in-one platform for
building your brand and growing your
business online
[Music]
hello my beautiful dubs my name is mina
um welcome or welcome back and today we
have a lot to discuss um i'm mainly
going to be talking about teenage
girlhood internet aesthetic trends and
what i call toxic femininity and if
you're a little lost uh don't worry it's
all going to make sense by the end of
this video
but i do want to start off by talking
about this one article that went a
little viral it was published on
id magazine it came out in june and the
article is written by roy's and langan
i'm going to read this very spicy
excerpt hey do you like listening to
lana del rey what about fiona apple
mitsky whole melanie martinez marina can
you recite the cool girl speech from
gone girl verbatim do you love that one
jacques louis david piece portrait of a
woman in white not because you care
about art but because you like the
broken female protagonists of a tessa
moshfeg's literature do you have a
favorite lisbon sister and is it lux are
you still mourning the loss of tumblr do
you like to read vladimir nabakov's
lolita do you enjoy catholic iconography
press to describe yourself or to have
others describe you would you be
comfortable with adjectives like toxic
or manipulative if the answer to any of
these questions is yes then
congratulations
you might be a femme cell
so this article got a lot of heat on
tick tock and twitter mostly for a lot
of reasons me personally when i read
this article the first thing that came
up into my head was
is this not just
tumblr sad girl 2014 culture
repackaged i mean gone girl came out in
like 2012 and i still remember people
making gifs and graphics using that
monologue that she says cool girl is hot
cool girl is gay cool girl is fun cool
girl never gets angry at her man um lana
del rey and marina and the diamonds were
like the poster girls of the tumblr sad
girl era
and we didn't have my year of rest in
relaxation but the vibes were the same
so none of this was like
seriously shocking to me to read about
other people read this and were
understandably upset by the
categorization of femme cell and the
implication that listening to fiona
apple would bring you anywhere close to
that identifier and for anyone who
doesn't know the term fem cell is short
for female involuntary celibate um aka
women who cannot get laid not by choice
and then they're just people who are
upset about being categorized at all for
having particular interests like just
because you read this one book and you
like it or just because you like this
one female artist why do you have to be
put and shoved into this aesthetic
category this tick talker posted a video
complaining about it with the caption
i'll never forgive you all for what
you've done to fiona apple she's not a
femme cell that is literally not a thing
and she's not a part of this stupid
niche girl interrupted red scare
coquette lana del rey diet coke kate
moss [__] leave her alone stop grouping
female artists into a box they never
agreed to be in she would hate those
people and i know it so i understand
these criticisms and complaints um but
as someone who's like perpetually online
and i mean that in the most derogatory
way possible i understand what lanigan
was getting on about because
yes there is this growing sub community
on the internet mostly on tick tock and
tumblr and twitter who
are using femcel as this aesthetic
designator who've become somewhat
obsessed with categorizing themselves
based on specific niche interests it
reminds me of this sub stack essay that
my friend rainfisher kwon wrote a few
months ago she writes it's become very
common for women online to express their
identities through an artfully curated
list of the things they consume or
aspire to consume and because young
women are conditioned to believe that
their identities are defined almost
entirely by their neuroses these
roundups of cultural trends and authors
du jour often implicitly serve to
sheekly signal one's mental illnesses to
the public
one girl on your tik-tok feed might be a
self-described joan didion eve babbitt's
marble red straight cut levi's fleabag
girl
this means she has depression another
will call herself a baby doll dress
sylvia plath red scare mew lana del rey
girl eating disorder or green juice claw
clip emma chamberlain yoga mat podcast
girl different eating disorder
the aesthetics of consumption have in
turn become a conduit to make the self
more easily consumable your existence as
a type of girl has almost nothing to do
with whether you actually read joan
didion or wear mewmew and everything to
do with whether you want to be seen as
the type of person who would so we're
going to be talking about all this in
just a minute but first a word from our
sponsor
on squarespace you have lots of
templates to choose from they've got a
design for just about everyone and even
then you can still customize your page
with backgrounds colors and or fonts
like i did here and of course
squarespace has powerful built-in
analytics so you can see who's visiting
your site and more with page views
traffic sources time on site most spread
content audience geography etc
you can also use squarespace to set up a
store if you have things to sell they
also let you put in subscription plans
if you want to sell a service
check out squarespace.com for free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.communilay
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
so the term that lanigan uses to
describe this niche that of interest or
describe this new aesthetic
is fem cell core but before we can talk
about what fem cell core is
we've got to start with the roots which
are unfortunately
skin cells
the word incel by the way stands for
involuntary celibate aka someone who
cannot get laid not by choice so in 1997
a canadian woman who goes by ilana and
nothing else um she has kept her
identity mostly anonymous she had
started dating and was having trouble
with relationships so she started this
website called alana's involuntary
celibate project
for anyone else who was also struggling
with the romance department it was a
simple website where she posted articles
ran a mailing list um and then evolved
into a forum where people would talk
about being lonely alana says there was
probably a bit of anger and some men
were a bit clueless about how women are
unique individual humans but in general
it was a supportive place the word incel
used to mean anybody of any gender who
was lonely had never had sex or who
hadn't had a relationship in a long time
fast forward to 2014 a 22 year old man
named elliot roger went on a shooting
and stabbing spree in isla vistas
california killing six people and
injuring 14 before offing himself it was
revealed that before his death he had
distributed a 141-page
document about his
hatred towards women that was caused by
his intense frustration of being a
virgin and then in 2018 25 year old alec
menacing drove his van into a crowded
sidewalk in toronto killing 10 people
and injuring 16. after the attack he
told investigators that he was an incel
and that his actions were a revenge plot
over
him not being able to get laid the incel
community has thus
developed in the worst way possible from
being a fringe internet group to a
recognized uh terrorist threat so we
compare them to fem cells the only real
shared thing is their belief that
they cannot have sex or cannot get into
romantic relationships because of their
looks or personality and even though a
lot of people feel this type of way at
least um during one point in their lives
fem cells believe there's something
significantly wrong with them that
makes them different from other women
according to the now defunct reddit
thread true fem cells to be a fem cell
you have to have defects that must
exceed those of normal women and exist
in a much more severe form as mel
magazine puts it fem cells were dealt a
shitty hand the sentiment goes and the
only way out of the lonely housescapes
they live in is to ascend themselves
speak forget hotter
since um the reddit thread has been
banned it's difficult to mine it for
content unless you know how to use like
internet archive tools but from articles
that i've read it sounds like unlike in
cell forms fem cells are non-violent for
the most part like there might be some
fringe person who's like
you know writing something truly
disturbing but for the most part most of
the content was focused on the women's
unhappiness with themselves and
unfortunately this retic is actually how
most women
tend to feel when navigating uh romantic
spheres tracy moore did an investigation
on nice girls um and found that women
most women
who blame their lack of sex or
relationships on their appearance
actually feel embarrassed or sorry for
inconveniencing the people that they
find attractive that's not to say that
there are absolutely no problems in the
femsel community though lorelei alvarson
researched fem cell forums and found
that despite several members identifying
as people of color the vast majority of
users across fem cell forums are white
and leverage this whiteness in disputes
there are also a lot of transphobic fem
cells who express anger towards trans
women who are able to get facial
feminization surgery covered by their
health insurance and i think even like
people who are not outwardly transphobic
um the lingo that's used among like fem
cells like fem cells speak and the
assumptions that they have about women
tend to fall into this like gender
essentialist like there are only two
genders
mindset
which ends up becoming a breeding ground
for transphobic trains of thought so
what i just described to you all is what
i consider to be traditional femme cells
traditional in the sense that in the
past couple years or so there's been a
different community of women who
identify themselves as fem cells but are
so far removed from all the lore that i
just talked about and these fem cells
which i'll call modern fem cells to be
less confusing is what that id article
was talking about the article even
clarifies the social media fem cells of
today use the term less as an indicator
of how much sex they're unable to have
and more as a way to express their
personality traits that are perceived as
pathetic or manipulative or toxic in
some way they do so unapologetically
romanticizing these stereotypical femme
cell traits in the process
modern fem cells mostly exist on like
twitter tik tok tumblr and they make sad
aesthetic spotify playlists titled
female manipulator anthems and songs for
your fleabag era by the way i've like
referenced fleabag eras
in previous videos but not yet in this
video and basically um fleabag is a tv
show that centers around this uh pretty
problematic female protagonist
and
the term fleabag era refers to anyone
who is essentially embracing chaos and
mess to deal with trauma rather than
seeking help
[Music]
lanigan writes new fem cells have
flourished on popular social media
platforms where it can be communicated
not through tortured posts about being
overlooked by men and self-hatred but
rather through a post-ironic
self-conscious embrace of aesthetic
feminine toxicity it's not femme cell
for these women it's fem cell core
for example one 19 year old tumbler user
named hannah who regularly uses the
hashtag themself said i just thought the
word was funny and maybe even a little
shocking i knew it would get people's
attention most of my posts are ironic
i've been in a relationship with my
boyfriend for two years
similarly a 22 year old tick talker
named alexandra carmona admitted her
female manipulator content is ironic she
told insider that it's not about
promoting actual manipulation it's about
calling ourselves out and coping with
our own issues by making a joke out of
it
so aesthetically i've noticed a lot of
overlap and a lot of line blurring
between
these femme cells these modern femme
cells um the coquette girls and ballet
core i've done a whole video on ballet
core but for coquette girls who partake
in it flock to frilly slip dresses hair
ribbons thigh-high socks mary janes
tight-fitting tank tops cropped
cardigans cheeky slogans on baby tees
and overall pastel colors and lace
trimmings popular aesthetic icons shared
by all three subgroups include lana del
rey particularly at the beginning of her
career nina sayers from black swan
angelina jolie's character and girl
interrupted jennifer from jennifer's
body gone girl and of course models and
actresses that have heroin chic or
wafe-like body types including lily rose
depp young kate moss bella hadid and mia
goth a lot of these girls also refer to
themselves as girl bloggers aka girly
girls who blog about being a girls girl
who have user names like dior waif or
cocaine bambi who post grainy gifs of
blonde 90s models mew mew ballet flats
young natalie portman lana del rey
lyrics patrick bateman and memes that
hint at or explicitly state mental
illness there's a lot of romanticization
about being pretty and mentally unstable
but that being okay because you're still
pretty and terminology like pilled
maxing uh being in your whatever
whatever era and esoteric get tossed
around there's also a very unique turn
of phrasing that these girls use bish
sherbert describes it in their article
on girl blogging
i'm unstable in a black swan the virgin
suicides nepotism baby cool girl
monologue sylvia plath brittany murphy
fatal attraction kind of way
a girl bloggers frequent lines of text
rubbed together into an inner monologue
that looms over all her posts
this diary voice psychologically charged
and often [__] like the writing on a
bathroom stall is what separates the
girl blogger from an impersonal mood
border with a similar taste for girly
things
[Music]
you can't keep getting away with this
so just to recap on what was happening
on tumblr around 2012-2015
a popular subculture on tumblr revolved
heavily around lana del rey jiffs and
lyrics black and white photos with side
captions overlaid on them and cigarette
self-harm and drug motifs and who can
forget the hashtag pretty when you cry
selfies
this was all part of a movement now
known as like the sad girl era rosemary
curtin defined a sad girl for id as one
who listens to better music than you and
might spend her alone time watching
french films from the 60s or angsty tv
shows from the 90s but even before the
2010s the sad girl was not a new
phenomenon like think of romeo and
juliet think of ophelia from hamlet
think of jane eyre and yes there were
always shared aesthetics and films and
songs that sad girls leaned on to as
rain puts it to sheekly signal one's
mental illness
but i will say it wasn't as self-aware
or self-commodifying as the girl
bloggers are today sad girls mostly
posted stream of conscious thoughts into
the void on tumblr um and our collective
interest in arctic monkeys and marina
and the diamonds music felt more like
coincidence than a calculated attempt to
aestheticize our own identities at this
time journalists were releasing think
pieces about how the sad girl aesthetic
movement romanticized clinical
depression and eating disorders which i
definitely agree that it was
i don't think it was intentional like i
don't think any movie director or any
songwriter was explicitly trying to
delegitimize
uh mental illness with their music but
that's just what happened and it
definitely didn't help that being sad
was considered cool and so a lot of
teenage girls who probably weren't
actually battling with serious mental
illnesses kind of induced traits of
those mental illnesses within themselves
as an attempt to fit in the sad girl
movement wasn't just pervasive on tumblr
though there were brands that were
selling pins tote bags and necklaces
with phrases like sad girl club and
other slogans on them hannah may wrote
for hello giggles even more disturbing
than teens using depression to be cool
is the possibility of companies
marketing depression to those teens to
make a quick buck granted i think one of
the main issues these days is how out of
hand consumerism has gotten
and consumerism is unfortunately a
byproduct of making everything into
different aesthetics i asked what people
thought about this topic on my instagram
stories a couple days ago and one person
said
i feel like now more than ever these
aesthetics are so intertwined with
consumerism trend cycles similarly
another person said we can let women be
angry without attaching an aesthetic
slash a title to it and yet another
person said i think it's really fun to
be in a community with lots of other
girls who like the same things as me but
it can also be really exclusionary and
breed a pikmi-esque mindset if you
aren't as indie slash enjoy too many
mainstream things or even dress somewhat
basic
i think these are all very valid points
i also think that they are
points that were valid back in the 2010s
if anyone remembers like the whole
hipster trend just so you know a
macchiato is a shot of espresso with a
little foam on top it's not a giant
latte slathered in whipped cream with
caramel squeezed all over it
hey what uh what band is this you've
never heard of it
um
to really qualify as a hipster it wasn't
enough to just
like the same things as everyone else or
have the same kind of ideology like you
had to get the square glasses you had to
wear the infinity scarves you had to
have some mustache motifs somewhere on
your body or else
um your friends were probably like are
you really a hipster and god forbid if
you want to listen to justin bieber
every once in a while the difference
between then and now is obviously like
social media because rather than just
having to gain approval from your local
group of friends the internet is so
global and now there's so many people
who belong to this community who you are
connected with
and who you are constantly seeking
approval from
not to mention the endless
content-focused mood boards that give
you
new consumers ideas of how to gain
people's approval but the biggest
problem i have with um commodifying
sadness even back in like the 2010s is
that it made wallowing in sadness cool
and getting help
uncool
similarly in the femme cell girl blogger
subculture by making
female hysteria and mental illness
aesthetic it discourages young women
from wanting to get help 22 year old
tick talker jules johnson told insider
that she finds the trend nihilistic and
hollow she said in the female
manipulator space there's a lot of focus
on getting back at men when you could
direct that energy towards loving other
women but anyways i think the tumblr
girl ideology redux was kind of
inevitable considering the style itself
is getting a renewed appreciation with
the tag hashtag 2014 tumblr having over
215 million views on tick tock fem cell
core also champions the thin body type
which is being echoed in the mainstream
with low rise pants and skirts coming
back in full force and even kim
kardashian slimming down her booty in
the past several months
i think some of you guys are forgetting
what kim k used to look like
look at the look
at the math
okay
this about 40 pounds of ass gone
because of how influential the
kardashians are and because they were
kind of the ones to popularize bbl's um
in the past 10 years to begin with
a lot of people feel like them
shrinking their asses is a sign that the
bbl era is over bbl by the way stands
for brazilian butt lift which is a very
dangerous procedure that shifts the fat
in your stomach into your booty to give
you a more curvaceous figure even
without the kardashians involvement it
might just be
the natural course
of body type trends that's dictating
this shift in silhouette because as we
all know very unfortunately throughout
the course of history
um
women's silhouettes have been
trends
it's dipped from curvy to skinny to
curvy to skinny and we've just been
curvy in the last 10 years and i guess
it's time to go back to skinny
obviously i think bbl's and kind of
escaping that phase is a good thing
because bbl's are incredibly dangerous
like you can literally die on the
operating table for getting one but
i don't think going the other end of the
spectrum is better because i grew up in
the 90s and 2000s like
everyone had an eating disorder because
of how
skinny everyone in the media was do you
know what really just kills me
about this whole thing it's the clothes
that you're gonna get i mean
you don't deserve them you eat carbs for
christ's sake
[Music]
even though i think it's somewhat
natural for
girls to feel like very angsty or to
feel a certain way about their place in
society
i also think that there have been
movements and trends that have occurred
in the past five years or so
that has also contributed to the rise of
fem cell core
for example during the first two years
of the pandemic there was a major
societal trend towards self-improvement
a lot of people felt pressured to
utilize their time in isolation
productively either by reading as many
books as possible listening to as many
podcasts as possible watching as many
movies as possible learning new skills
um getting fit
dieting you name it the desire for
self-improvement gave rise to the that
girl trend which was a major trend on
tick tock and instagram and revolved
around girls who essentially had their
lives together or at least looked like
they had their lives together
these girls would film themselves waking
up at 5am going on runs doing pilates in
the morning i'm drinking green smoothies
uh
wearing like beige athleisure sets
and
meditating
journaling gratitude journaling
regularly just doing everything that we
feel we are supposed to do for our
mental and physical health all while
looking absolutely amazing
while some people were inspired by the
whole that girl trend to get their life
together um a lot of people also felt
very
uninspired because they felt like the
trend was inaccessible for people who
were not white skinny or at least upper
middle class
laura pitcher wrote an article on that
girl for id last year noting that it was
a rebranding of girl boss culture
similar to other fitness videos on
social media being that girl means
encompassing a life based on mainstream
notions of wellness however there's
bizarrely no end goal no marathon you
train up to no reason to wake up at 5
a.m other than that it seems more
efficient
and this is just like a general thing
with our society like a general problem
where a lot of our health goals are
focused on aesthetic motivations rather
than scientific ones for example a lot
of like dieting books talk about how to
lose weight but not
why you should want to lose weight
because our dieting culture revolves
around looking thin
not being healthier for whatever your
body type allows it actually
is
a healthy thing for their body to do but
just because they feel like it's more
aesthetically productive
so because there's a lot of pressure to
constantly be improving yourself
it makes sense that there would
inevitably be a movement that pushes
back against that kind of rhetoric gia
tolentino wrote in her book trick mirror
the ideal woman has always been
conceptually overworked an inorganic
thing engineered to look natural
figuring out how to get better at being
a woman is a ridiculous and often amoral
project
a lot of girls have taken this
uh desire to not be perfect to the
extreme though
lanigan also wrote another article
earlier this year talking about feral
girl summer which explored the part
satirical but part very true desire to
just be imperfect the ultimate power of
being in your fleabag era or being a
femme cell or embracing a feral girl
summer is that you're allegedly
self-aware
you're aware that womanhood is
oppressive and rather than trying to
lean in and hustle till you die you've
just decided to give up sit back and be
cynical it's ironically kind of i'm not
like the other girl's ideology despite
its heavy reliance on feminine
aesthetics i don't think having like a
little nihilistic era every so often in
your life is a bad thing inherently but
i think it can be dangerous if it goes
to extreme or if it becomes so
mainstream that it takes up
valuable conversation space for actually
productive feminist action
as haley mcniff writes if women are
drawing accepting their pain as inborn
and inevitable there may be an
empowering sense of numbness in fully
embracing that pain and running headlong
into it yourself and even bringing
others down with you if you so choose
it's definitely frustrating and one of
like the number one complaints i got
from my instagram stories were
women saying
that
the movement is just
not
reasonable for a woman of color or a
girl of color to partake in aurora moore
wrote a great article on this and how
disassociating to the world's problems
keeps oppressors comfortably empowered
she writes these white dissociating
feminists are holding up their hands and
saying there is nothing i can do about
it the world is just too [__] up for
me to help i'm going to have to lie down
she also offers the alternative of
community care and love
being a person is [__] hard and it's
[__] horrible sometimes but i'd like
to give our daughters and sisters a
world they want to be a part of where
they can laugh and love as opposed to
one so bitter they must wither
themselves away in an effort to spare
themselves from it i don't think all
modern femme cells are bitter by the way
i think some of them have derived some
kind of sick pleasure and being stuck in
the system um
kind of like a stockholm syndrome
but i do agree with murr overall i think
a lot can be said about how nihilism can
numb us from making any progress
and rather than just flipping the script
on girl bosses and being like girls
don't actually have to
lean in and work super hard and be the
best it's worth like just
having more productive conversations on
how we can make girl hood and womanhood
more bearable and even enjoyable without
being self-destructive but you know what
do i know i was a teenage girl once too
okay everyone that's all i have for
today thank you so much for tuning in
please let me know in the comments what
you think about
toxic femininity and all the things that
i've discussed today i would love to
hear your input i feel like it's one of
those topics that has become
way more involved to discuss about and
therefore has piqued my interest because
i keep seeing like new and interesting
takes about it and i'm just like very
interested i guess in like
women's studies because
i am one
thank you for sticking around i hope you
have a lovely rest of your day and i'll
see you next time bye